être père devenir père
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que cela veut dire
pour le savoir nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de quatre nouveaux papas à la
maternité du chu de dijon
c'est frédéric qui le premier nous donne
sa définition de la paternité
sa petite manon est née la veille moi
m'a fait beaucoup de responsabilités
c'est
la vie qui change avoir pensé à 3
maintenant plus qu'à 2 et puis c
une longue histoire qui commence
l'histoire une histoire à inventer pour
yannick aussi ce papa comédien s'apprête
à jouer les premiers rôles mais sans
trop savoir comment on va improviser sur
l'aventuré consultations sur cette
histoire
voilà d'être peints à d'avoir des
enfants c'est aujourd'hui c'est pas
évident pour moi d'en parler je sais que
j'ai dit à peu près ce que je veux mais
je pense que c'est aujourd'hui au jour
le jour qu'on apprend à devenir papa on
n'est pas pas du jour au lendemain papa
sylvain les déjà de trois filles dont il
est très proche avec son petit garçon il
veut être aussi complice est présent moi
j'ai donné mon père qui était un père un
peu en retrait et justement on en
parlait en ce moment c'est des moments
qui manque en fait et moi j'ai envie que
mes filles avec plein de souvenirs avec
moi de deux moments partagés de deux
choses qu'on a partagé ensemble un père
qui veut être là pour ses enfants mais
qui travaillera autant qu'avant pour
samuel c'est une question d'équilibré
je prends quelques jours oui non peut
pas non plus tout sacrifié au petit re
passer un juste milieu à trouver aussi
c'est un juste milieu à trouver entre la
vie professionnelle et la vie
personnelle
en tout cas moi je mens pas nous fait
pas si je me consacrais un seul disque
de travailler moins pour pouponner plus
aucun des papas que nous avons
rencontrés à la maternité n'a voulu
sauter le pas pourtant certains le font
yoann à 28 ans il travaille en usine
metteur au point de machines et de
systèmes d'emballage
depuis quelques semaines il quitte
l'atelier bien avant ses collègues
yoann a pris un congé parental à temps
partiel ça me permet de quitter mon
entreprise plus tôt pour aller rejoindre
ma fille plutôt est donc là c'est donc
cette entreprise de 400 salariés ce
jeune papa est le premier à bénéficier
d'un congé parental et il fait déjà des
envieux parmi ses collègues
c'est pas mal pour lui la 80 %
ça me permet de
de s'occuper de sa poupée de gamme a
donc assez bien pour nous et vous vous
émerveiller personnes quand vous serez
pas pas à votre tour c'est un jour je
suis papa que
j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire où ça se
passerait bien également une demi-heure
plus tard yoann on retrouve sa petite
fille jeanne quatre mois tout juste
chez son assistante maternelle des
retrouvailles qui arrivent même à
attendrir la nounou chauds sur les vols
qui viennent chercher les enfants
donc c'est assez agréable aussi voilà
est-ce qu'il a les mêmes réflexions
qu'une maman voyez je pense même plus il
est plus les inquiète l'ue attend
surtout c'est pas pareil
de retour chez lui yoann va passer la
fin d'après midi seul avec sa petite
fille
des moments de complicité auquel le
jeune papa assez vite habitué à 18
heures la maman de jeanne stéphanie qui
est enseignante rentre à son tour du
travail et est tout gentil cette planète
avant même la naissance de leur bébé
stéphanie et yoann avait décidé de
partager les tâches
alors même si maman est de retour c'est
papa qui se soit change la couche
que ce soit pour le change le biberon le
bain quoi que ce soit c'est suivant si
c'est le papa ou la maman quai
disponibles
celui qui est disponible s'y colle en
fait pendant les six mois de son congé
parental
yoann ne quitte pas seulement lusine
plus tôt le soir ils ne travaillent pas
non plus le vendredi une vraie
opportunité pour les jeunes parents
comme moi je suis professeur des écoles
et que
cette année je suis encore sur
l'ancienne réforme où je ne travaille
pas le mercredi on s'est dit que comme
j'avais une journée en milieu de semaine
avec jeanne ce serait bien qu si le papa
puissante elle fit il aussi ma journée
tout seul avec jeanne en fait qu'on a
chacun une journée vraiment le papa avec
sa fille et la maman et sa fille ont mis
un territoire coupé profiter notre fille
quoi a pu avoir une évolution de la
monogamie avec un changement du rôle des
sexes des applications des mâles
beaucoup plus important des
comportements parentaux
on peut aussi avoir une défense conjoint
territoire entre mâles et femelles on
peut avoir un réquilibrage on va dire du
rôle des salles françaises y est
biologiste professeur à l'université de
bourgogne
et ce jour-là il dispense un cours
d'écologie comportementale son thème
l'influencé de l'environnement sur les
rôles des mâles et des femelles dans les
soins parentaux des rôles qui dans de
nombreuses espèces ont évolué au fil du
temps le scientifique c'est précisément
interrogé sur les visages de la
paternité dans la nature
il y consacre même son dernier ouvrage
sa conclusion il n'ya pas de modèle
parental prédéfinis cas des flamants
roses par exemple souvent les pères sont
plus à même de d'accompagner le jeune
ans qui grandit de faire un effort
supplémentaire pour le nourrir parce que
lorsque femelle un petit peu atteignent
leurs limites
donc on a des pertes réinvestir nature
et c'est une image un petit peu fausse
que de dire que les pères sont
naturellement pas disposé à donner son
parentaux ce pas dire qu'ils sont
majoritaires à le faire la nature il ya
plus d'espèces où sont les femelles qui
ne sera pas en tout mais atteint un
nombre conséquent d'espèces ou sont soit
que les mâles soient les mâles et les
femelles à parts égales ou à peu près
égales qui donne ce pas
retour à nos jeunes parents stéphanie et
yonne qui expérimente avec bonheur
l'équité des tâches depuis l'arrivée de
leur petite fille se rencontrent au
quotidien à bas on peut partager
certes c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être un
petit peu plus de douceur avec la moment
c'est un prénom
on peut pas lui enlever mais bon pour le
reste ça se passe très bien que ça
souvent les clubs avec l'autre enfin
dans notre corps tout se passe très bien
cet enfant jame dira peut être plus tard
ce qu'elle en pense yoann qui lui
consacre tous ses vendredi à sa fille ne
céderait sa place pour rien au monde
c'est dommage de ne pas profiter de son
enfant tant qu'on peut quoi après ça
avec tous ces petits moments passés
pendant ces premiers mois pour moi je
trouve ça quand même vraiment important
après si doute préfet
allez travailler plutôt que passer du
temps avec leurs enfants bombe à chacun
sa façon de voir les choses mais bon
pour moi ça me semble quand même très
important et papa au foyer ou ça vous
gênerait pas non pas du tout pas du tout
frapperait les mentalités évoluent
monsieur auchan madame à la maison je
pense que c'est on a changé d'époque
et pourtant aujourd'hui en france seuls
3 % des bénéficiaires du congé parental
sont des hommes
non